[Musique]
Donald Trump Angela feta La Maison
Blanche la championne polonaise du super bowl
plaît bien les Eagles de
Philadelphie ou F est une limitation
initiales briseida une certitude Donald
Trump le mérite
licky accompli nous aimons notre pays nous
respectons notre drapeau le président Trump
Ethel halète totalement NFL  Dupree ou pas de mal
dénonce lavake a protesté membre national
voir le football puisque votre compte libère l'
intérêt cela devrait être un palais 'pour l'
Amérique ce pays représente la liberté
liberté justice pour tous et cela ne
se produit pas pour tous en ce moment
soupe facile Colin Kapernick voies au
mouvement de la guitare donc aujourd'hui  Tripoli Liberty
Ellis repose mon tireur d'élite POTUS comme Raziel
Trump beaucoup un petit genre confortable NFL
n'entend pas juste préparer Schiller bien
le manifeste II n'aimeriez-vous pas voir l'
un de ces propriétaires de la NFL quand quelqu'un
manque de respect à notre drapeau pour dire obtenir ce fils
de  une chienne hors du terrain en ce moment
il est viré
il est viré et je pense qu'aucun président
un homme vaincu en C NEPA attorne  y pour
me laisser échanger un PC et ne laissez pas
Donald Trump qui
essaie de diviser tout notre pays
ne lui permet pas de diviser cette équipe non
Lisa petrm une division de plombiers d'accord gardez le
football de village communautaire LeBron James
la méga star  du basket-ball
Napolitano pour entourer un championnat national du
prix de présence du champion du gang de La Maison Blanche SIL
est bien plus grand que
Dean invité à la Maison Blanche
Je veux profiter de cette occasion pour
expliquer pourquoi les jeunes Américains défendent
notre hymne national
peut-être qu'il est temps petits colons
images seulement président
pourquoi à foucha tornade boo zoo
Harlem Nacional Donald Trump Donald moins
sur les Patriots est Maj bien les Eagles
ha absence à Blom gardons en fait
qui étaient la société Orchestra ec cristal
à hey Raju Canada Washington